by the way these are all bars i got a
rap about zebra cakes
[Music]
what's up world i'm joey bettes and
these are new york bodegas snacks
[Applause]
so first of all a bodega is a new york
city essential
bodegas might be primarily the reason
why
i've never left new york and it's hard
to leave because i just can't get over
the fact of it being 3 a.m
and me not having any options that's
what the bodega is it's a 24
7 essential all-in-one
shop stop store all right so first off
i got some pastries right here you know
i got the nice lady linda honey bun
this is a classic certified hostess
coffee cakes and a zebra case
i'm not gonna lie i don't know what this
cake roll business is i'm an og
zebra cake head they trying to make a
twinkie the [ __ ] is going on here but
zebra cakes is also a very good snack
very
underrated this is like the after school
snacks right here you know what i'm
saying is like
you had a long day in school answering a
whole bunch of math questions
that you probably would never even need
in life you're leaving
you walk to the bodega that's right
around the corner from the school or
right across the street and you go get
you some some pastries because you got a
sweet tooth it's
3 45 and you know what i'm saying you
want to feel a little nice you want a
little sugar rush so you go get your
zebra cakes and your coffee cakes and
your honey buns
[Music]
you still got that same crunch when you
bite into it
so next up we're moving on to the drinks
right now i got a
arizona iced tea classic flavor and i
got two quarter waters
these right here got us through some
tough times this this is literally
literally cost a quarter for some juice
god knows what the [ __ ] they put in this
[ __ ]
but boy did it quench our thirst when we
needed it
desperate times go for desperate
measures
in arizona ice tea this is also a
classic we should just call these aries
you got arizona
every morning before school and that was
it you're baking egg and cheese with
your arizona and you were set you had
the breakfast
of a champion no
i drink water down real water
we got some kisco freezies right here
now if you never seen these right here
let me tell you these are
a bodega classic welcome to the bodega
you say what up to oct right in front of
his um register or whatever he got the
freezer
and you open up the freezer and then
boom they got a whole bunch of freezies
any color any flavor that you need
[ __ ] every day of the summer in bed
style you know we was going to the
corner store
getting some freezies about 1 p.m and
you probably already had a zebra cake by
the end you know but
yeah this is this is an essential right
here this is very nostalgic
me seeing this
[Music]
well yeah so right here i got uh tate's
bake shop cookies now i must say
i really do like taste cookies but this
is something that was introduced later
on in life once the neighborhood started
changing up a little bit got a little
bit more
gentrified we got introduced to some
more gourmet high level snacks
say say you walk into a bodega and you
see these
you're probably real close to
williamsburg park slow you know what i'm
saying
if you ain't got these in the bodega you
probably in flatbush you in crown
heights you know what i'm saying like
maybe best stop maybe some of both
diggers the best i still didn't get
these yet but i know some it
it hit some of those stores out there
but the snacks in the boat they could
tell you a lot about where you at like
if you were just dropped in the bodega
like say you got kidnapped and you woke
up oh i'm in a bodega you look at the
snacks on the shelves you could probably
figure out where you at geographically
you got to be cool with with your guy in
the book
because then you build a level of trust
and once you got the level of trust
you know your moms can send you to the
corner store and you know get that six
pack of beers and like he won't trip
because he know you know it ain't for
you
but it's very important to have a
relationship with your bodega man
because
he's part of the community you know what
i'm saying it's like
knowing the [ __ ] crossing guard or
some [ __ ] like that
shout out to my man mike i think he went
back to armenia and [ __ ] but like if you
see this
love got the vienna sausages by the way
these are
i got a rap about zebra cakes i gotta
rap about all of this [ __ ]
all right so now right here what i have
is vienna sausages this is super
nostalgic for me
this is uh satisfied my hunger on
on many days man many many times in my
past in my adolescent years
i used to feed for these vegan sausages
pause i used to wake up my grandmom's at
like all hours of the night like can you
make
some sausages and [ __ ] please my belly
hurting and [ __ ] like
i've been eating vienna sausages since
the packaging was red
like this blue [ __ ] this is new that's
how long i've been on vienna sausages
but i do not eat these anymore thank god
i
probably haven't eaten one of these and
like no [ __ ] like 10 years
but boy did it satisfy my hunger when i
was younger
[Music]
my name is joey badass and you're
watching snack cause these are my
personal favorites
i hope you enjoyed that keep it up
you